des étirements qui semble facile mais
pour ces participants la maladie ou
l'âge les rendre plus compliquée ils
prennent leur deuxième cours d'activités
sportives adaptées pour pouvoir en fait
être acquérir de l'autonomie pour
pouvoir garder une forme même créé que
gérard bientôt 80 ans et je veux rester
en forme le plus longtemps possible
le sport sur ordonnance inscrit dans la
loi de modernisation de santé de 2016
l'activité physique est prescrite comme
thérapies non médicamenteuses
ça va être une pratique qu'on va
modifier pour que les gens qui ont des
pathologies ou des troubles physiques
soit capable de les faire sans danger
pour eux et pour leur psyché donc c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué parce que ce
sont des personnes qu'on doit surveiller
avec beaucoup d'attention mais ce sont
des personnes qui peuvent reprendre goût
au sport saint quentin en yvelines le
lance sur son territoire en novembre
2010 est sa demande
la construction de ce dispositif ce port
sans ordonnance l'implication de
différents acteurs les médecins bien sûr
mais aussi les clubs sportifs qui
doivent se certifier à l'activité
physique adaptée et parallèlement dans
la construction elle ce dispositif qui
au niveau régional se décline sous la
forme prescrit forme actuellement quatre
créneaux pour quinze personnes sont
proposés et déjà victimes de leur succès
les cycles vont de 12 à 15 séances mais
on peut déjà faire de l'activité
physique à la maison il est recommandé
de marché au minimum 30 minutes par jour